a mí
no
[Música]
hace 134 años cuando los hermanos
lumière proyectaron esta imagen en un
café de parís la gente salió corriendo
porque pensó que ese tren se les iba a
venir encima era la primera imagen que
tenía movimiento ahora sí quiero que
vean lo siguiente
gente le compro el tren pero hay un
sentimiento que vende más
[Música]
y atravesaron
a
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tal como ustedes lo acaban de leer el
inquisidor es la primera serie hecha
toda con dispositivos móviles del mundo
se hizo con celulares con cámaras de
computador con tablets con go pros y con
cámaras de seguridad y de eso
precisamente quiero venir a hablarles
hoy de la revolución audiovisual pero
antes de entender la revolución
audiovisual porque además hace parte de
los pilares fundamentales de la cuarta
revolución industrial que es la digital
porque hoy el 75% de la población del
mundo se está grabando todos nos
grabamos todos queremos ser
protagonistas de nuestras propias
historias las queremos contar antes de
conocer eso es súper importante que
entendamos que ha sido del audiovisual
en colombia y por ejemplo con el cine
en colombia uno dura tres años
escribiendo la película conozco casos de
tres años haciendo en la fila el fdc al
fondo de desarrollo cinematográfico que
es el único recurso que tenemos para
producir películas en colombia y que
gracias a ese fondo pasamos de tres
películas a 40 películas y una semana en
cartelera
porque porque pues obviamente estamos
enfrentados a 'rápido y furioso' aquaman
y nuestras películas colombianas tienen
45 mil espectadores que seguramente si
la suba en youtube puede llegar a tener
mucho más espectadores
así la proyectó en una sala de cine
contra dos o tres millones de
espectadores que tienen las películas de
hollywood eso que hace que el cine sea
completamente excluyente y que no
tengamos la posibilidad de tener acceso
a él así que si usted soñaba con ser un
súper director de cine que le dice la
mamá papito se va a morir de hambre
y va una vez y es verdad
entonces todo el ejercicio alrededor del
cine es plata y eso lo hace excluyente
pero aparte de eso no tenemos plata y
somos muy creídos y entonces existe una
elite que si no nos llega a los
estándares de intelectualidad que tienen
ellos pues es absolutamente difícil
entrar ahí si usted es actriz de
televisión no hace películas
queremos actores naturales y se vuelve
un ejercicio muy muy excluyente
entonces juan beltrán un creativo de mi
compañía un día haciendo un casting para
una película colombiana lo hizo todo con
celular esto pase siete años era
rarísimo uno como actor llegar y que le
hicieran un casting con celular no como
que sentía que no le estaban parando
bolas al tema y se hizo con celular solo
por transferencia de datos porque era
mucho más fácil hacerlo con el celular y
mandarle un grupo de whatsapp y todo el
mundo ay opinaba está gorda está flaca
fea bonita mala actriz sirve no sirve
chau next el que sigue ahora imagínense
esto con una cámara cámara grave
descargue material solo el computador
mande lo por white transfer que lo
descarguen que lo vean y eso más o menos
nos estaba comiendo ocho días de casting
con el celular era inmediato así que
cuando dijo oiga por qué no nos
inventamos un festival de cine hecho con
celulares colombia tiene 72 festivales
de cine nadie quiere uno más porque
además es absolutamente difícil
financiar los y monetizar los entonces
cuando dijo el festival de cine no pero
cuando dijo celulares
esto es absolutamente innovador y le
dije juan si le encuentras un objetivo
que nos mueva el corazón nos montamos y
lo encontró y fue la democratización del
cine que todo el mundo lo pudiera hacer
y que todo el mundo lo pudiera ver y la
manera de lograr esto era generando
cuatro categorías fundamentales la
juvenil chicos entre los 13 y los 17
años haciendo películas con sus
celulares la aficionada que es cualquier
persona que tenga un celular y quiera
contar su historia usted usted usted
usted lee la historia que contar' a gale
para los profesionales que no los íbamos
a excluir también estaba su cupo y era
todos los que tenían estándares de
calidad en guión en producción en
actuación y una que se le inventó el
exministro david luna que me dijo si vas
a tener el festival de cine más
incluyente del mundo te faltan las
personas en condición de discapacidad
yo lo confieso y siempre le doy el
crédito a él porque yo dije que no yo
elige no estamos hablando de audio
visual
ciegos sordos discapacidad física
discapacidad cognitiva
pues les quiero contar que la limitada
era yo porque en smartphones los ciegos
y los sordos hacen película el primer
año se lo ganaron cuatro ciegos de la
ciudad de medellín el segundo año unos
sordos de bogotá con un test con un
cortometraje que se encuentra en
competencia en el festival de cine de
argentina
entonces empezamos a notar
que la gente quería contar historias
pero como yo me estaba metiendo con una
cosa muy rara que era el celular para
hacer cine yo sabía que si yo no me
montaba en un festival que tuviera toda
la etiqueta y el glamour de los
festivales emblemáticos del mundo pues
no iba a pasar nada
así que nos montamos con todos los
juguetes y nuestros participantes se
sienten en cannes estrenan sus cortos
alfombra roja mamá estoy triunfando los
nominados son se visten todo eso pasan
smartphones
todo eso pasa en smart team porque el el
cine con celular
era inimaginable no a eso llamarle
cualquier cosa pero no le pongas la
palabra cine yo más o menos era como la
madame del cine
porque me atrevía a hacer lo que nadie
quería hacer y era hacer cine con
celular y buscar la manera de monetizar
lo de que todo el mundo tuviera acceso
al festival
pero lo que empezamos a notar eran las
cifras de smartphones smartphones 25.000
participantes 28 países
107 ciudades de colombia
no solamente lo teníamos en colombia
sino que méxico lo quiso y ya lleva dos
años en mexico ahora españa lo está
pidiendo y empezamos a preguntarnos qué
era lo que pasaba con smartphones porque
tanto éxito en este festival porque la
gente quiere contar historias
porque las historias nos construyen las
historias no sanan
las historias construyen las culturas
las historias son las que hoy en día
están mandando la parada en la
publicidad en el marketing hace muchos
años una empresa de máquinas de afeitar
salía súper innovadora tenemos tres
cuchillas que no le cortan nos dé la
cara y mi papá de hoy las compraba hoy
en día a esa misma empresa le toca salir
y comprometerse con el storytelling y
hablar de masculinidades tóxicas y decir
oiga loco venga hace una nena pasa no le
mire la cola
bueno pues con eso aumentaron sus ventas
porque los famosos en tenias millennials
son una audiencia y los consumidores que
leen etiquetas
en mi oficina está la empresa de la
patrocinar y no hoy es esta empresa
contamina
tienen conciencia social ambiental
entonces ya no es tan fácil para las
marcas hay que humanizarse hay que
comprometerse con el mundo y por eso
quiero mencionarles hoy a un escritor
muy famoso israelí que está súper top
contemporáneo y es no
yuval no a parar y que en su libro de
animales a dioses dice que los seres
humanos desarrollamos nuestro cerebro
cuando nos inventamos el chisme
qué es el chisme las ganas que tenemos
de contar historias así que en el martes
nos comprometimos con un ejercicio muy
bonito y fue una agenda académica
preciosa que hemos llevado por todo el
país y es decirles a todos ustedes si
usted tiene un celular y tiene una
historia que contar nosotros les
enseñamos cómo y descubrir esa
herramienta de comunicación qué es una
de las herramientas de comunicación más
importantes que existe hoy en día en la
humanidad y es el celular en el celular
puede desarrollar una película completa
encontrar cuáles son las aplicaciones
con las que puedes editar
con cuales puedes capturar el sonido hay
una aplicación que uno diría esto es un
dinero significativo para una aplicación
que puede valer 100 dólares y te vuelve
el celular una cámara completamente
profesional pero pasamos de una
aplicación que vale 100 dólares
a un equipo que valía 100 mil dólares
eso es una real democratización eso es
un ejercicio democratización porque
tienen acceso todas las personas del
mundo a contar sus historias hoy en día
ya no dependemos de las grandes
compañías para divulgar y para hacer
nuestras historias
así que como todos ustedes saben pues
tengo un festival de cine hecho con
celulares innovador y a la vanguardia
pero hoy más
qué respuestas quiero dejarles muchas
preguntas porque la iniciativa de
haberles contado lo innovador que era el
celular
pero lo más innovador que son las
historias es porque no me interesa
incentivar que compren celulares
me interesa incentivar la creatividad y
la imaginación porque es lo único que no
va a ser reemplazado por la inteligencia
artificial y es la creatividad
todos nosotros sabemos que somos un
algoritmo
y como decían ahorita en una charla que
es un algoritmo no sé no tengo ni idea
pero que soy un algoritmo lo soy
me manipulan la información sí porque
ese algoritmo te sectoriza y qué pasa
cuando a mí me manipulan y me dicen es
que esta mujer le gustan estos zapatos y
esta ropa me da en un solo punto de
vista y no me permite en otro punto de
vista
o sea que si estoy manipulada
en mi compañía que está llena de zenten
y el sí de millennials alguna vez fui a
un celular para cambiar una lista
de reproducción de spotify y me dice mi
community manager no ya ese me vas a
cambiar mi algoritmo
porque iba a poner mi música
claro que somos un algoritmo y lo peor
es que ya teníamos conciencia de que
somos un algoritmo hasta dónde es la
línea amarilla de nuestra relación con
la tecnología y de nuestra relación con
el pensamiento y con ese ejercicio que
pretendo hacer y que quiere lograr
quiero
mostrarles esta imagen este fue el
primer celular que se inventó motorola
el primero fue inventado el 3 de abril
de 1973 y para se poderlo comprar
necesitaba más de 3 mil dólares en el 73
era un motorola dynatac 8000x pesaba un
kilo su batería duraba una hora
y como decían en otra charla eso era
para millonarios
pero ellos lo hicieron con un fin y el
fin de ellos era unir a las personas y
era que el celular nos uniera
hoy en día el celular nos une o nos
desune
hoy en día usted controla la tecnología
o la tecnología lo controla usted
cuál es el ejercicio que tenemos
nosotros como seres humanos frente a
toda esta cantidad de información que
nos llega nos llega al día a día en otra
charla también decían no nos dejemos
polarizar quien no se está polarizando
cuál es el ejercicio que están haciendo
con nosotros y si somos nosotros capaces
de detener eso de frenarlo y de
controlar yo mi pensamiento y lo que soy
el celular está catalogado como el
músculo 640 del cuerpo
usted puede dejar a su marido a sus
hijos a que sea pero el celular no
se no se queda en ninguna parte
este terminó siendo el amigo disque fiel
y para cerrar quiero dejarles esta frase
y es que estamos efectivamente en la era
de la tecnología pero tenemos que
retornar a la era del arte de la
creatividad y del pensamiento por favor
muchos más
sócrates aristóteles y si ustedes
quieren comprobarlo la profesión más
contratada en sillicon valley son los
filósofos gracias
[Aplausos]